welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today and tomorrow
and
let's talk a little bit more about the
january 6 hearings but
let's go a different approach right
we've talked about the hearings we've
talked about what's been uncovered
but one thing we need to talk about too
is the republican response
i mean obviously
we have had some pretty massive
revelations from these uh committee
hearings so massive in fact that even
some of the folks on fox news
even fox news hosts
have come out and said this looks really
bad for trump
they have had paid fox news analysts on
the air this week that have said
i believe you could hit trump with
criminal charges obstruction of congress
to be specific
so
even the folks at fox news not all of
them not even a majority
but a couple of them
starting to see those cracks form
looking at what's happening and saying
uh-oh
this is pretty bad
so if even fox news is saying that you
gotta assume the republicans in congress
not the ones implicated in the schemes
but the other ones you know the regular
ones
certainly
they've been moved by what we've seen
right
well no or at least they're pretending
that they're not moved by anything that
we have seen
in fact a recent report from the hill
this week
kind of highlighted a bunch of different
republican responses to what we've seen
so far from the committee so let me read
you
some of these responses that these
republican senators these are all
senators this is what they told
reporters from the hill first up we have
senate minority leader whip
john thune not minority leader sorry
senate minority whip john thune
to the degree that there are any people
who haven't made up their minds or don't
have an opinion one way or the other
maybe something comes out of this that
changes that
but it just seems like right now it's
mostly rehashing ground
okay
remember that phrase by the way
senator shelly moore capito from west
virginia says
yeah they're significant
but i'm not sure it's going to change
anyone's mind
okay
then we have senator kevin cramer from
north dakota
who says
no one's ever said anything to me about
it back home
i don't know that i know anybody that's
watched it no one has ever brought it up
as an issue
riddle me this senator cramer
when was the last time you were back in
north dakota we actually spoke to
constituents
they not lectured them not gave a speech
but actually you know maybe you walked
into a diner maybe you did a town hall
but but i would love to see evidence of
you actually talking to people in them
saying we haven't watched any of it
because i'm willing to bet that hasn't
actually happened has it
yeah that just seems like something you
probably didn't actually do
republican senator mike rounds from
south dakota
says he watched the first day of the
hearings in parts of the second day and
then he said i think they did a very
nice production they spent their time
efficiently but they didn't tell me
anything that i didn't already know
so we're back to that theme right like
ah this is all old news everybody knows
all these things that happen come on hit
me with the good stuff they say
lisa murkowski
alaska
said that the panel is quote basically
saying this is a rehash of everything
out there
a rehash
it's the second time we've heard that
word from a republican senator offering
a response to what we've learned
from these january 6 committee hearings
it's rehash
it's old news they're all telling us the
same things we've heard all this before
play some new material
well okay
i first have to say it almost seems as
if all of these responses are somehow
coordinated right
yeah i'm fully
willing to bet republicans probably sent
out a memo that eventually will make its
way public telling republican senators
how to respond to all of this downplay
downplay downplay say that oh this is
nothing we didn't already know
but here's the thing
there's a lot of stuff we didn't already
know there there's been a lot of new
material i mean sure i've watched these
hearings and a lot of it i do say like
yes okay i knew that i knew that
but here's the thing and this is what
these republican senators have to
understand as well and they do
understand let's be clear they
understand it they're pretending they
don't understand it
these hearings are not for me
in fact honestly these hearings probably
aren't for you either
if you're watching this
you're a daily consumer pretty much of
political news
you're up on the issues you understand
things you know these things
these hearings aren't for you
these hearings aren't for the
republicans in the senate these hearings
are for the millions upon millions upon
millions of americans who haven't paid
attention to any of this
and again you as a daily news consumer
probably think that that's weird right
that are there really people like that
folks the majority of america doesn't
consume any political news on a daily
basis
let me tell the story this way
the very first hearing
my wife was sitting right next to me on
the couch as we're watching this
she she had no interest in it and she's
a teacher so the day of the capital riot
she wasn't glued to the tv she's
teaching her class she she didn't get to
see any of the footage
she wanted to actually leave say i don't
care about this i don't want to see it
but she ended up glued to the tv that
night
in shock
because she had never seen it
i had seen the footage
i had read stories about the testimony
that they were playing
but she hadn't
and she was shocked
just absolutely floored
that all of this took place shocked at
the beatings
that we were seeing these rioters do
against police officers that
is who these hearings are for
those people the people who yeah they
understand yeah january 6 i know
something happened it was bad
but they didn't quite understand it
because they're not daily political news
consumers
and again and i know that sounds weird
folks that yes there are people out
there
most people do not do this on a daily
basis even fox news right on a good
night
they're breaking what three million
viewers in prime time
seems like a lot right
it's less than one percent of the
population
you add in the people who watch
political news on youtube
msnbc cnn add all that together
maybe maybe
you got five percent of the u.s
population
maybe
consuming daily political news either
from conservative liberal or neutral
sources doesn't matter
90 to 95 percent of the country out
there isn't doing that
they may tune in to the local news in
the evenings you know find out what's
happening in their community you know
local sports get the weather for
tomorrow and that's it
they wake up they shower they go to work
they come home they get the kids they
make dinner
they watch a sitcom they you know binge
some tv shows and they go to bed and
they do it all again the next day
those are the people that these hearings
are for and as far as we can tell those
are the people that these hearings are
reaching
so for these republicans to act like oh
it's no big deal there's nothing new
it may not be new to you
but there are millions of americans
who've never seen this and never heard
this and it is having a major impact
on how they feel about american politics
just remains to be seen of course
how big that impact is going to be
next time folks head to the ballot box
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds
this has happened to me before i've
talked on the show we got hacked it was
costly it wasn't a good feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors protecting your
accounts and devices gets complicated
because you need a bunch of different
tools and aura combines them all into
one app identity theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below